all right so the final drop of the
morning i'll begin by rahul causal
difference with corrupted
thanks this is a joint project with a
niche initially you like to wait
we're both uh fellows here at simon's
for the semester in causal inference
anisha is also a postdoc at uc berkeley
and i'm a phd at mit
the motivation for this project is the
2020 u.s census united states census is
a very important data set it's high
dimensional it's actually required by
the us constitution that they provide
this and it's ubiquitous in social
science and policy making decisions made
by the fed by the department of labor
and uh and the council of economic
advisors for example are based on data
published by the bureau some slowly
breaking news is starting with this
census it'll be published with
differential privacy
and i'd like to read an excerpt from the
census website they say
we're deploying differential privacy the
gold standard for privacy protection
computer science and cryptography to
preserve confidentiality in the 2020
census and beyond
there are many variants of differential
privacy the one selected for the 2020
census introduces controlled noise into
the data in a manner that preserves the
accuracy at higher levels of geography
and this is worrisome for
people who use the census and census
data
to inform policy to do call inference
and in fact from in the statistics
literature there's a warning that there
will be a painful trade-off between
privacy and precision and in the
economics literature there is
even from about who is the chief
scientist of the census a warning that
this is a painful trade-off we have to
make
now why does the census need privacy
to the credit of the u.s census bureau
they actually simulated an attack in the
2010 census
so
they took
they took different commercial data sets
and these commercial data sets have
let's say names and addresses
and then they tried to use that to merge
with census data and see what's revealed
in particular what did they find they
said that our simulated attacks
demonstrated that depending on the
quality of the external data used
between 52 and 175 million respondents
in the 2010 census can be correctly
re-identified from the reconstructed
micro data
and
this had big shock waves and immediately
they kind of pivoted the policy of how
they're going to be publishing data in
20 census and hereafter
another recent announcement related to
this privacy protection issue is that
they're going to discretize certain
variables that they release such as
wages
now wages are really important for
economists
and
some have already documented what this
might do so there's something called the
atlanta fed wage tracker the fed is
part of the federal reserve system
and they track wages over time
they have these plots of wage growth
that people use to inform policy
you can see the original data series
before thinking about how discretization
will be implemented and it's this kind
of blue slash green series
but if you implement the discretization
they've proposed you get this red series
so you can see it's very corrupted and
this is very worrisome
there was a big backlash and actually
the the census bureau announced that
they will delay this policy until maybe
inflation abates or something like that
so what does this mean for causal
inference
[Music]
social scientists are worried about
these
new types of data corruption of course
to people here at simon's these might
not sound new like differential privacy
and discretization
but even before the 2020 census
these data sets had kind of old or
classical types of data corruption which
are very much studied in causal
inference such as missing values and
measurement error
now what's the standard practice what's
the standard workflow for let's say an
economist trying to measure
a treatment effect from one of these
data sets
well they'll do some data cleaning and
then they'll do some data analysis that
kind of ignores the bias and variance
consequences of the data cleaning
in particular what are those
consequences roughly speaking well when
you clean a data set you tend to make it
more homogeneous and correlated than it
originally was
and in the effort to rein in the bias
from different types of data corruption
you've probably also really depleted the
variance
existing confidence intervals ignore
this phenomenon and in simulations you
can show that typically they'll be too
small too optimistic coverage will be
about 70 instead of the 95 you'd expect
so what's the kind of solution that we
would like
well
we would ideally have a solution that
estimates causal parameters as if the
data were uncorrupted
yet still adjusts for data cleaning in
the confidence interval
we want this procedure to not require
knowledge of the corruption covariance
structure as well
if such a procedure existed it would in
some sense preempt this looming
trade-off between privacy and protection
sorry privacy and precision
that is faced by social scientists and
other researchers who use these data
sets
this is maybe the most important slide
why is this hard
i think that several challenges arise
and here are just a few of them first of
all
when we justify confidence intervals
we typically
appeal to a central limit theorem that
requires independence or at least weak
dependence among observations
meanwhile
data cleaning in general induces really
strong dependence across observations
that you need and even if you think
about it across every single entry
the next
issue is that if we think of the data
cleaning literature perhaps return to
the matrix completion literature we see
results that at if we want relatively
good rates
are for recovering not
matrix entries
uh entry wise or in max norm but rather
kind of matrix entries on averages
across rows and columns a fabrinius norm
type of idea and so i think a conceptual
question is how is this even related to
causal inference
a third challenge
happens to be about
how fast are these rates we get from the
matrix completion literature
and the best ones are
going to be actually a little bit slower
than n to the minus a half if rank is
increasing
so how could we possibly get a standard
error that is of order n to the minus a
half
these are i think three difficult
technical challenges that we are going
to try to address
and here's what we propose in our
project we're going to propose an
end-to-end procedure that includes data
cleaning estimation and finally
inference with a data cleaning adjusted
confidence interval
now theoretically we'll prove root n
consistency
gaussian approximation and semi
parametric efficiency
throughout it's going to be finite
sample arguments at each step and our
key assumption is that the true
covariates are approximately low rank
in doing so we try to overcome the
trade-off between privacy and precision
where we think about privacy as being at
the individual level and precision at
being at the population level
if you believe our conditions
then indeed we have
i'd love to talk more here's my email
address and maybe i can take some
questions
argument at the end so it's going to
involve a kind of sample splitting
and we'll develop a new theory of
anticipated cleaning that preserves
independence across worlds
triangular
regular arrays
so maybe i'm not really
i don't know how census 2020 is working
but
what is the meaning of the freight
discretization i mean
i i thought that the data
would have every day it's not uh any
other
term so what is the meaningful
differentiation
so uh wages
are reported
for for example this variable what is
your hourly wage and that is
continuous in the sense that it's up to
the cent reported historically
the census bureau which publishes many
data sets said that hereafter we're
going to round to the nearest 50 cents
a lot of information is lost
we can do that
one of the things we'll do in the papers
we'll propose well if you want to
discretize here's a way to discretize
it's not actually just rounding to the
nearest 50 cents it's kind of doing a
discrete process that's centered at the
truth
and if you do it this way
then you can still get the causal
influence you want downstream
yeah maybe just take an opportunity with
this crowd that there's been a bit of a
breakthrough both at stanford and
michael's kind of business group ours
here on conformal prediction
so you can get uncertainty distribution
free
non-asymptotic and you don't need
independence you need exchangeability
and
i think a lot of what you're doing with
this kind of thing and conformal is
actually kind of like we have a private
prediction sets paper where we talk
about doing this with their program so
here you know i think a lot of
theoreticians would do if you haven't
looked at the check they want to because
it's there's a lot of open periodical
questions about it
uh thanks to all the fellows for uh
range of topics and thanks all for
coming and i hope to see all of you
after that
you